And our zip code of the day today,
8-0-2-0-3, shout out to Denver, Colorado.
(audience cheering)
That's right!
Hello, Denver!
Home of our affiliate station, KCNC
CBS 4.
Now, Denver is nicknamed the Mile High City
because it sits exactly one mile above sea level.
The Denver Mint produces about 40 million coins a day
and about 70% of that
are pennies.
I love pennies, especially picking up lucky pennies
heads up on the street.
It holds the second largest gold bullion deposit
in the US, holding $100 billion
worth of solid gold bars.
Denver, Colorado, we would love to hear from you.
Please send us some mail.
Okay, now let's get started.
We're gonna read our first letter.
Just so you know, I open these for the first time on air.
Makes it more fun.
Okay.
Let's see.
Dear Drew and crew.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Hello Ashley from The Drewseum here.
Oh!
The Drewseum is this wonderful museum about me
which is weird because I don't know why anyone
would wanna do that,
but here I have been enjoying the show so very much.
My daughter and I were lucky enough
to be VFFs a few weeks ago.
She was inspired and wanted to send Drew some artwork.
She asked me what's Drew's favorite thing besides children
and I promptly answered mac and cheese.
Ashley, you know me so well.
So that was the motivation behind her cute drawing
that we've enclosed and we hope you enjoy it.
First of all, Ashley, don't be a stranger,
we've hung out many times.
Okay.
Mila, thank you so much and I will be framing this
and it will be going on my wall.
In fact, let's see here.
Why don't we just put it up right now,
even though I hate putting a hole in it
but I can fix that later.
Okay, oh, God, hold on.
(Drew sighing)
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
Look, Mila!
I love it!
Thank you, Mila and Ashley.
Thanks, guys.
Okay, our second letter is...
Here we go.
I'm old, 64.
That's not old.
For one of my first retirement adventures,
I'd like to find and explore some mining properties
that Howard Hughes owned and frequented.
I purchased a retirement motorcycle.
Cool, and a Jeep for these adventures
but could use a new state-of-the-art metal detector
to find Howard's artifacts, could you help?
I'll split 'em with you.
First of all, of course, Lance Campbell
from Jackson, California.
I am inspired by your plan, so I'm sending you $1,000.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
So you can get that metal detector of your dreams
and start your own adventure.
I'm so happy for this chapter of your life.
By the way, there is one request,
will you send us some pictures and updates
and keep in touch?
Okay, thank you.
We have time for one more, and this is from Trish Ramel
in Sheboygan, Wisconsin.
Dear Drew, I actually have a recipe box
with actual recipe cards.
(Drew gasping)
I love them and I've shared them with many people
and I ran out of people to give recipes to so, tag,
I like your style, anyway,
I can't believe you never ate spam,
sent you a favorite recipe for mac salad with spam.
Maybe you can test it on the show.
I hope you like it, love, Trish.
Okay, these recipes are absolutely
gorgeous.
I absolutely will cherish these.
Thank you so much.
This is treasure.
Thank you.
I'm really glad that you spammed me.
(audience laughing)
Get it?
There's spam in my mailbox, but I'm not upset
because you included these wonderful recipes
and this absolute treasure, I love them.
I have been wanting to try spam again.
What's this?
Thank you, Paulie.
(audience laughing)
Wait, what?
Oh, my gosh.
I'm like,
macaroni
salad?
You sent the recipe, so we made it.
Trish!
Oh no, you didn't.
It's so good!
Recipe, mac salad, here it is, okay, Trish.
One pound rotini, frozen peas, Miracle Whip,
that's the taste.
I love it.
Yellow mustard, apple cider vinegar, sugar.
Thank you so much!
Thank you, Trish.
Okay, if any of you guys out there want advice, help,
maybe you wanna try something new,
mail me your questions, requests, photos,
funny or heartfelt stories, and to find out more,
get our address, go to TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com/DearDrew.
I can't wait to read more of your letters live on the show.
Ashley and Mila and Lance and Trish,
thank you so much for your letters.
And here are my postcards to you.
That, okay.
Truly yours, Drew.
(upbeat music)